because when you were directing yourself
said how hard was it as an actor not to
do voices because that is kind of your
life um yeah I mean it was it was uh it
was it was less of a leap than I was
then I feared it would be you know
they're doing Family Guy I had gotten
into the into the habit of being able to
record a line and then go into the booth
and listen to it and switch off my brain
and kind of feel like I was listen I'm
listening to somebody else yeah and that
did kick in pretty early on into the
process where I was able to run into
video village and look at the you know
look at the footage and see if I was
doing doing it right my voice is do you
do sir I want me to take over your
interview just kind of curious like how
many can you do oh you know just enough
to avoid being myself visually it son
family Guy Family Guy if I do the
characters you do you do Peter Brian
Stewie quagmire and then a smattering of
others located and are they all based on
people or you just there they come from
various places Peter I knew a thousand
Peter Griffin's growing up in New
England guys who would not think before
they spoke like ever no self editing
mechanism everything it's coming out
here with no gateway and then Stewie is
is based on your own Rex Harrison was a
big fan of Wow yeah
Quagmire's quagmire frog that can't be a
perfect quagmire if it is he's not happy
no he's a bad egg he hit quagmire when I
was a kid my father used to buy me old
radio dramas from the 40s and 50s that's
right so I would listen to these things
and the commercials were intact you hear
these old commercials you know auto like
brand sparkplugs
the only spark plugs for you and like
everyone had this high-pitched voice
which I guess the mics were more
sensitive to the mid-range voice at that
time and they all sounded like quagmire
and so that kind of stuck with me and
when I was coming up with a voice for
him that he began as a as an impression
of 1950s ad men and when you're doing
because you know those characters are in
scenes together yeah do you do one line
after the other or do you all do all one
and then go back to the other one when I
do a table read yeah I have to jump back
and forth right okay how much going on
hello sad man doing away it's good right
that is good
but then sometimes you do them
separately
yet when I when I record the shows I
kind of literally do it one line at a
time just to just to make sure that but
that's not really because of the voices
it's just cuz you have to be naked
completely naked for Brian completely
the essence of yourself yeah completely
emotionally and physically nude OPG the
moon with thing what the cool I feel
like it's like dance like I'm just gonna
I can see it I can open it you know
you're an Irishman you think these
people accept you as one of their own
but they do um yes if I'm who's like
some cool whip but like why are you
saying it like that what am I say I'm
saying cool whip oh you're saying cool
hwhip yes I'm take cool quit a lot of
emphasis on the age cool quit I say cool
quit okay cool cool say whip
it's all recycled vaudeville humor now
as soon as that it not the only person
on the couch who does who does voices
because we've heard releases Bach the
Salafi and coke yeah very good
it was I'm sampling it it's gonna be my
ringtone oh but no Emily Blunt what I
heard you earlier you do do a TCH
you didn't uh see uh after Seth I mean
come on
Shelley's your goat noise God you want
do what line the top Oh what line should
I do
I don't know I feel the need the need
for speed look at it
how'd you Donald Duck keep that with
that you do Donald Duck yeah do you do
it okay now it's your turn
adorable that's that's gonna be my text
message alert and and my last bit of
getting a stick and poking Seth is I
don't know what that means is to Liam
Neeson Liam Neeson in a million ways by
the West so did you ever do you're takin
your version of the taken phone call for
him I think I did this
the moment our version on Family Guy was
Kermit the Frog doing doing taping yeah
I'm not gonna be able member the speech
um I don't have any money
but when I do have a very specific set
of skills skills that make me a
nightmare for somebody like you if you
don't let the girl go all right we'll
track you down all right we'll find you
and I will kill you
just turns to me and he goes Jonah Jonah
Bobo no banana fanna fo fonna me mama
Mona action hero he's always running in
film and other way runs he doesn't just
like this I watched it a lot so I'm kind
of an expert doing it now